DAZHI PENG: Hi, Kyas, you're asking, although they can, using, checking the free going on this week.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, some are exciting. Some are depressing. The exciting news is that open AI. Release its latest multi-model Gbd: 4 model.
Jeffrey Feng: Well, that's capable than you lose in many real world scenarios
Jeffrey Feng: exhibits human level performance on various professional and academic benchmarks. For example, it passes a simulated bar exam with the score around the top. 10% of test acres in contrast. Gbd 3.5 score was around the bottom 10%.
Yooni Choi: This was so exciting. Can't imagine what youpt for can do, since Chat ipt is so powerful Already I have been using Chat to extensively for my everyday work.
DAZHI PENG: Gb. Detroit is so powerful, according to open I Ivd. For the CD. In the most recent public available task is a case of Olympics and ap free response questions. or by producing 2,022 to 2023 patients of pricing them and they they know specifically training for this series.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, I think what's more exciting, that Gpd: 4 can even accept visual. Input
Jeffrey Feng: There was an example on opening a website that the user asks: what's funny about this image? Describe it panel by panel and Gbd. For successfully identify all the interesting features of that image.
Yooni Choi: Given these features, I think it's definitely worthwhile for us to do a deep dive into its capabilities. Dr. Would you be able to take on the action? Item, to read open AI's technical report for Gpt for and present a summary of it to the team.
DAZHI PENG: Well, i'm pretty pleased this week, so I don't think I could.
Jeffrey Feng: That's fine. I'll take it
Jeffrey Feng: at the same time the bad news in the tech industry. It that matter started another round of layoff last
Jeffrey Feng: November.
Jeffrey Feng: I think Matt, are plan to lay off are about
Jeffrey Feng: 10,000 employees, or, roughly, 13% of his workforce.
Yooni Choi: That's a lot of people I remember Meta already laid off 10,000 employees last year. The layoffs will affect me as recording team this week, with a rec restructuring of his tech and business groups to come in April and May, Mr. Zuckerberg said in a memo posted on the company's website.
DAZHI PENG: I also heard it lay up. We involve a lot of let me do layer management people.
DAZHI PENG: Oh, my
Jeffrey Feng: yeah, this is an interesting question for us to investigate as well
Jeffrey Feng: whether too much middle management people are actually helping or hurting the company.
Yooni Choi: It makes sense because Meta has kept changing from members to AI, or vice versa. There is definitely something wrong with their leadership structure
DAZHI PENG: there you need when nicely would you like to work on
DAZHI PENG: Maxine? I'm, curiously whether the middle management layer is helping
DAZHI PENG: more slow in the
Yooni Choi: No. I think we don't need to do so. I think it's just too much work.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, let's just not do it. Anyway, this is an interesting discussion. Have a good week guys.